[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24 il
y a deux ans jour pour jour la chine
annoncé un premier mort du co vite 19 il
s'agissait d'un homme de 61 ans qui
fréquentait le marché aux animaux de
wuhan longtemps considéré comme le
premier foyer de l'épidémie le 23
janvier suivant où anne était confiné
aujourd'hui le bilan mondial de
l'épidémie et 2 5 millions cinq cent
mille morts dans le monde la chine
maintient sa stratégie sderot qu'ovide à
quelques semaines des jeux olympiques
d'hiver mais la vague omicron commence
aussi à toucher le pays la ville
d'anyang a été placé à son tour en
quarantaine deux ans après l'apparition
du coït 19 à one en sait-on un peu plus
sur l'origine du coc vide où la chine
reste tel fermé à toute nouvelle enquête
l'eau mikron va t'il obligé la chine à
revenir sur sa politique zéro co vide
cette stratégie zéro co vide est elle un
enjeu plus politique que sanitaire pour
pékin à un mois des jo de pékin comment
le gouvernement chinois se prépare-t-il
qu'elle est finalement la stratégie
vaccinale de la chine dans le pays et
dans les pays pauvres en afrique
notamment on en discute ce soir avec
baptiste falgos qui m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau baptiste bonsoir journaliste de
france 24 ancien correspondant en chine
de france 24 nous avons par skype de
paris jean joseph boillot bonsoir à vous
bienvenus économiste spécialiste de la
chine à l'iris membres du cercle cyclope
hauteur de utopie mais deal monde et
c'est aux éditions odile jacob
également avec nous parce qu'elle
toujours hansen et qian sénéquier
bonsoir médecin co directrice de
l'observatoire de santé mondiale à
l'iris bonsoir et bienvenue également à
vous merci il ya deux ans jour pour jour
je le disais la chine annonçait donc son
premier mort de kobe de 19 c'était un
homme habitué du marché de one le 11
mars 2020 le chef de l' oms annonce une
pandémie on les écoute
un oubli
consult
severity
la
réforme la semaine tu dois être convient
de martine knb caractèrise
pandémique et que je vais commencer par
vous tout a commencé donc dans ce marché
de one on se souvient donc du patron
l'om est-ce qui parle de pandémie
justement ce fameux 11 mars 2020 il y a
eu une enquête de l'om est mené en chine
une enquête qui a été contrariée par les
autorités de pékin est ce qu'on en sait
plus sur l'origine tout de même dû kobe
de 19 2 ans après ce qu'il est d'origine
animale ou s'agit-il d'une fuite du
laboratoire de warren on a toujours des
doutes en tout cas en ce qui concerne le
patient zéro en chine
oui c'est toujours une question qui
n'est pas répondu c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une première étude en 2021
internationale dont les résultats ont
été rendus le 30 mars avec une étude qui
estimé que le passage du coronavirus de
la chauve souris à l'homme il ya un
animal intermédiaire était le scénario
le plus probable est évoqué le scénario
de la fuite de laboratoire comme très
peu probable c'est vrai que c'est
finalement des résultats qui ne convient
à personne parce qu'il est très
important pour arriver à gérer cette
pandémie et pouvoir prévenir les autres
de savoir comment comment la commune est
apparue essais et c'est dû à travers le
monde c'est vrai que du coup aujourd'hui
l'om s et les états unis en première
ligne on me demandait une nouvelle
enquête
avec une fin de non recevoir absolue de
la part de chine qui évoque une première
enquête à laquelle elle a participé en
toute transparence et qu'elle estime
qu'il ne faut pas repartir de zéro que
ça viendrait entaché la vie privée le
secret médical de ces patients est par
contre elle estime qu' elle peut tout à
fait travailler avec l' oms sur une
étude dite scientifique pour rechercher
les origines de cette de cette pandémie
donc c'est vrai que malgré les demandes
de loi mais de ne pas politiser cette
recherche l'origine de du virus sasser
grandement politisé et aujourd'hui on
n'en sait toujours pas plus cependant l
oms continue à rechercher cette origine
elle vient de créer le groupe
consultatif scientifique sur les
origines des nouveaux agents pathogènes
le sagot ses 26 experts internationaux
dont une vétérinaire chinoise
il ya pour objectif justement
d'identifier
l'émergence des nouveaux agents
pathogènes dont lakovic 19 encore une
fois mais deux nouvelles de nouvelles
encore une fois on se heurte à des
difficultés scientifiques mais aussi
logistique et politique et pauline et
c'est vrai deux ans plus tard on n'a
toujours pas de certitudes quant à
l'origine de celui quant à l'origine de
ce virus est tout de même assez
incroyable jean joseph boillot dès le
mois de janvier 2010 on se le temps
d'échanger des vélos oui oui vous avez
bien là dès le mois de janvier 2020 on
se souvient de ce médecin chinois le
docteur li wei liang il a donné l alerte
à l'époque sur les dangers du virus en
chine il a été interpellé par les
autorités chinoises puis il a été
infectée il est mort à l'âge de 34 ans
il est devenu sorte de martyrs le martin
le martyr qui a ébranlé le système
chinois c'est comme ça qu'on le perçoit
jean joseph boillot allez-y voilà la
stratégie chinois s'est pas seulement
celle de zéro co vide parce que quand
vous regardez le tableau mondial et en
particulier en asie les stratégies 0
copies dont été utilisée subie par une
dizaine de pays dont la nouvelle zélande
taïwan etc la particularité de la chine
c'est c'est une stratégie de 0 kobe
autoritaire alors que celle de par
exemple dans le lot pose souvent assez
de taïwan ou de nouvelle-zélande qui est
démocratique et donc la particularité du
système chinois de façon par pékin de
prendre cette
épidémie à bras le corps après il faut
le dire la honte de lujan parce que
maurane c'est précisément à l'intérieur
d'un système autoritaire c'est classique
l'opacité si vous voulez la peur du
niveau subalterne vis-à-vis des
autorités donc chacun a essayé de cacher
l'information et on sait qu'en réalité
c'est à partir du mois de novembre que
les choses
commencez à à se dérégler nous cacher la
mort de ce médecin également ce médecin
chinois qui a alerté avant tout le monde
bien sûr c'est à dire qu'on a commencé
pas caché au niveau des autorités
locales et provinciales
les premiers cas qui étaient apparues
dès le mois de novembre d'accord et
ensuite lorsque le poids centrale a bien
vu qu'on ne pouvait plus arrêter le
désastre
à ce moment là vous avez vu qu'ils ont
sanctionné le pouvoir local par les
autorités locales mais surtout ils ont
commencé à essayer d'étouffer toute
circulation libre de l'information c'est
la particularité de la réponse de pékin
à la pandémie c'est pas celle du zéro co
vide car on peut discuter des avantages
inconvénients de la stratégie zéro
copine la stratégie chinoise et la
stratégie extrême par rapport à l'autre
stratégie extrême qui a tenté un moment
donné la grande bretagne qui est celle
vous avez de l'immunité collective et
c'est celle qui a été choisie par l'inde
dans un premier temps et c'est vrai que
de ce point de vue là si vous voulez
entre la chine et l'inde sur le plan
sanitaire et économique il n'y a pas eu
photo entre les deux stratégies mais je
tiens à a bien insisté là dessus c'est
une stratégie autoritaire autoritaristes
et qui a en plus été à l'origine du
développement par les autorités de pékin
de tout un ensemble d'applications
informatiques qui était déjà testé
disponibles etc mais qui sont vraiment
là devenu la norme courante et c'est le
monde orwelliens qui s'est installée à
l'occasion de cette épidémie baptiste
talbot justement cette stratégie zéro co
vide comme le souligne jean joseph
boillot c'est une stratégie sanitaire
aux politiques cette stratégie
autoritaire des locaux vides déjà je
voudrais quand même préciser une chose
c'est qu'on peut parler aujourd'hui deux
seuls pays qui a une stratégie zéro co
vide certes elle est autoritaire par
rapport à l'australie par rapport à
singapour par rapport à la nouvelle
zélande mais ces pays l'ont levée
aujourd'hui ils ont accepté de lever le
couvercle et de laisser circuler le
moins possible le virus mais le laisser
circuler la chine elle est encore sur du
zéro co lead stricte sanitaire économie
ou politique les deux sanitaires je
pense qu'aujourd'hui alors malgré ce qui
s'est passé de catastrophique haouran
dissimulation d'informations on peut je
pense quand même dire que la chine à
l'épidémie sous contrôle alors si on en
croit les chiffres officiels bien sûr
avec toutes les précautions d'usagé
cohésion nationale voilà on est à cent
mille contamination moins de 5000 morts
vu ce qu'il s'est passé au départ
haouran c'est des chiffres quand même
qu'il faut vraiment certainement
remettre en cause en tout cas au début
de l'épidémie sanitaire oui politique
énormément également puisque à travers
sa stratégie c'est aussi un modèle que
la chine met en avant un modèle
autoritaire un modèle qu'elle veut
efficace en opposition à ce modèle des
pays occidentaux qu'elle juge
désorganisé ces pays occidentaux qu'elle
a accusé un moment de laisser mourir les
personnes âgées je vous rappelle qu'il
avait quand même eu un un article émis
par l'ambassade de chine en france l'an
dernier qui accusait les personnels des
pattes de laisser mourir les personnes
âgées dans les hôpitaux dans les ehpad
pardon donc voilà il ya aussi ce modèle
qui ont mis en avant à destination de
l'opinion publique mondiale mais aussi à
destination de la population chinoise
elle-même de plus en plus contrôler
cette population alors voilà
l'interlocuteur précédent j'en fais le
boulot a expliqué hier joseph
application jeunesse pardon toutes ces
applications de tracking de contrôle
social qui ne font que s'accentuer avec
la gestion de cette pandémie mais voilà
clairement aujourd'hui c'est en fait
c'est un modèle politique dans lequel
elle s'est un peu emprisonné la chine
puisque aujourd'hui ça serait difficile
imaginons aussi jean ping ou en tout cas
le gouvernement dira bon finalement allé
laissant circuler notre modèle n'était
peut-être pas idéal on va laisser
circuler le virus l'occident avez en
partie raison alors qu'il ya deux
échéances qui sont sains les jeux
olympiques de pékin et surtout surtout
le renouvellement le 20ème congrès du
parti aura lieu à l'automne prochain et
qui doit renouveler le mandat jean ping
troisième mandat c'est inédit anne
sénéquier est ce que la vague omicron
qui commence à toucher la chine puisque
on a certaines certains chiffres la
ville de danyang par exemple qui compte
cinq millions d'habitants au centre de
la chine qui a été placé en quarantaine
il re confine à ce que l'eau mikron va
remettre en cause cette stratégie du
zéro co vide en chine
la chine depuis le début c'est s'est
comporté un peu comment un état
insulaire une collègue est évoquée
justement les différents états qui
avaient choisi la stratégie co lead et
tous sont des îles il est l'islande
aussi et on a pu considérer finalement
la chine avait cette capacité aussi de
se considérer comme comme une île la
grande différence avec omikron et on le
voit bien quand lorsqu'on regarde la
dynamique de la pandémie à travers le
monde à travers les différentes régions
en fait c'est la première fois que la
vague touche toutes les régions
d'habitude on avait parfois l'amérique
latine parfois l'inde parfois l'europe
là on a un pic d'incidence sur toutes
les régions du monde et c'est vrai que
du coup il est fort probable du fait de
la très grande transmis bilité et des
flux encore une fois de population de
marchandises et c'est que la chine
[Musique]
soit mise à mal dans sa stratégie zéro
co vite face à un agent pathogène qui
est aussi transmissibles que l'eau
mikron donc mise à mal ou changement de
stratégie derrière à votre avis hansen
et qu'elle pourrait effectivement
je suis complètement d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit sur la stratégie de
gestion de l'épidémie chinoise qui est
beaucoup plus politique que sanitaire et
c'est vrai qu'avant qu'ils reviennent
sur leur stratégie je pense qu'il va
falloir vraiment passer par des étapes
que l'on n'a pas encore passé et
j'anticipe un petit peu sur la suite de
l'émission mais lorsqu'on voit le
protocole qui a été mis en place pour
les jo on voit que pour l'instant la
ligne directrice et le zéro co vide jean
joseph boillot il faut quand même évoqué
les dérives de cette stratégie à vous
parliez de contrôle avec tous les
appareils les les iphones et autres et
puis j'ai vu qu'il y avait certaines
personnes qui se retrouvaient en
situation presque de faim c'est à dire
qu'ils ne peuvent plus sortir de chez
eux ils n'ont plus accès à de la
nourriture ce sont des personnes qui
sont testés re testé dans le froid en
pleine nuit une serre violence en
permanence de la police et on ne parle
même pas des voyageurs des voyageurs
pour qui les règles sont encore plus
strictes trois semaines de quarantaine
avec des tests quotidiens dans le nez
dans la gorge prise de sang la chine est
en fait est aujourd'hui vraiment le seul
pays à aller jusque là alors bon d'abord
ce n'est pas un pays il faut vraiment
faire attention et ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure et est très judicieux les les
pays qui ont choisi des stratégies 0
copines sont en général des îles ou en
tout cas des enclaves qui sont capables
regardez singapour par exemple
e il faut bien rentrer dans la peau de
du monde chinois et cela pas seulement
des autorités mais du monde chinois j'ai
de la famille qui habite là-bas et je
vois bien comment ils le vivent on a
fait un aller un empire mais si vous
laissez 1 milliard 500 millions
d'habitants c'est un espace physique qui
est capable de se fermer complètement à
la fois par les maires et puis vous avez
cessé ses montagnes ses déserts à l'est
et au sud donc dans la mentalité et
c'est là que j'insiste beaucoup dans mon
livre je crois que la politique la
géopolitique doit s'imprégner de de ce
qu'on appelle les cultures où les
mentalités dans la mentalité des
autorités de pékin c'est ce qui s'était
passé pendant la révolution culturelle
ou la révulsion chinoise on ferme tout
on ferme tout et d'ailleurs j'aimerais
continuer ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure qui paraît très justes dont il
ou non continuer cette stratégie qui est
largement politique alors je rajoute
largement géopolitique je dirais d'abord
géopolitique fondamentalement
fondamentalement géopolitique s'assurer
que le contrôle sanitaire de la
population chinoise reste aux mains des
autorités de pékin elle est ensuite
politique vis-à-vis de la population
intérieur c'est intérieur qui ne se
rebelle pas population qui ne peuvent
pas s'en mêler c'est la trouille si vous
voulez des autorités chinoises en
permanence qui était dit tout à l'heure
et est tout à fait exact il ya le
congrès est là qui est pas loin il ya
des remous au sein du parti on sait on a
de nombreux sinologue je ne suis pas
mais qui insiste bien sur la difficulté
qu'il ya pour sing sing à asseoir son
autorité
pour un troisième mandat et en
conséquence de quoi l'ensemble de ces
facteurs contribuent à ce qu'il me
semble être la
possible évolution du modèle chinois
qu'on peut lire dans les 36 stratagème
qui est un vieil ouvrage de la
diplomatie de la guerre d'aptilo zoppi
de la guerre chez les chinois le 36 les
36 stratagème est le 36e c'est la cuite
la fuite rien n'empêche je pense de
concevoir que dans les années à venir
puisqu'il semble acquis que on va vivre
dans un monde pandémique structurelles
la chine ne ferme en réalité pour
l'essentiel son territoire elle et elle
met en place des centres de quarantaine
en ce moment qui vont être des sas de de
mise en quarantaine des gens qui vont
rentrer ou sortir peut pas sortir
d'ailleurs mais rentrer en chine elle
est en train de se doter d'un modèle qui
va à la fois sur le plan géopolitique
concevoir un empire face à l' empire
américain et ses alliés sur le plan
économique elle et regardez bien ce qui
se passe depuis quelques années elle est
de plus en plus autonome elle ne va pas
se fermer sur plan technologique mais
laisse et entreprises américaines qui se
ruent sur le marché chinois aujourd'hui
dans tous les secteurs et ce faisant
elle va continuer à utiliser ce qui
était dit tout à l'heure je souscris
tout à fait elle utilise une stratégie
sanitaire pour une stratégie
géopolitique
politique et et sociale le coût
politique et social ces c'est du tout
politique à vous écouter baptismale vaut
ce qu'elle devra être tout quel va être
l'impact de même de l'eau mikron sur les
jo de pékin les géo démarre le 4 février
donc c'est très bientôt ils vont avoir
lieu du 4 au 20 février
il n'y aura pas de public comment ça va
se passer alors il y aura pas de pluie
alors y'a pas de public étranger c'est
sûr public chinois s'est pas encore
décidé là on est là on est allé un peu
plus de trois semaines trois semaines
des jo on ne sait pas encore dans quelle
mesure le public chinois aura accès aux
installations et aux différents
différentes compétitions bull sanitaire
totale s'est
vu d'ici ça absolument dingue quand on
voit que les athlètes ne doivent les
athlètes les cuisiniers les chauffeurs
ne doivent avoir à aucun moment un
contact avec la population extérieure
donc il ya une sorte de cordon sanitaire
totale qui est mise en place depuis
l'arrivée des attelles l'aéroport
jusqu'au site olympique avec ensuite les
circulations entre les différents sites
olympiques qui se font de façon
totalement isolé du reste de la
population ce soit par des trains
spéciaux que ce soit par des convois
spéciaux les gens qui vont travailler
sur le site olympique sont déjà arrivés
sur place et sont actuellement en
quarantaine et ne doivent plus mélangés
avec les populations qui viennent de
l'extérieur il ya même alors là c'est
vraiment la panacée vous avez la
municipalité de pékin qui a dit
récemment que si les gens assistent et
un accident de voiture qui impliquait
des voitures liés au village olympique
les ces gens n'avaient pas droit
d'intervenir voilà il fallait attendre
l'arrivée de personnel spécialisé pour
les secours en attendant d'y toucher 6
après on voit là ça va se faire comme
dans une ambiance très particulière avec
cette bulle sanitaires et oui clairement
et comique rôle est d'aider le
gouvernement chinois est inquiétant et
peut-être cannes sénéquier pourra
revenir là dessus c'est intéressant mais
aussi d'autres questions avec omikron
qui se passe qui se posent le degré
d'immunité de la population chinoise qui
a comme été très peu exposées à ce virus
et puis aussi le vaccin alors là c'est
intéressant parce que face à un micro
est visiblement de vaccins chinois les
premières études montrent c'est pas très
concluante sénèque et justement je
voulais enchaîner avec vous sur ce
vaccin la chine a mis au point plusieurs
vaccins d'ailleurs le fameux sinovac qui
serait efficace d'après ce que j'ai lu à
seulement 35 % selon une étude publiée
par des chercheurs universitaires hong
kong donc des vaccins peu efficace on
parle même pas de son efficacité face à
l'ô mikron est ce que cette stratégie
zéro co vite finalement de la chine
est-ce qu'elles marquent l'échec de la
stratégie vaccinale de la chine
tout est relatif et c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux choses où nous parler d'échec de la
stratégie vaccinale là encore une fois
je pense qu'il ya un côté nationale et
un côté international et je pense qu'en
termes de géopolitique du vaccin la
chine a largement profité et même
peut-être le grand vainqueur de cette
année 2000 2021 sur sur la géopolitique
du vaccin et pour pour dire vrai en
occident on a sept cette notion que
les vaccins sinopharm et si novak ne
sont pas efficaces et bien ça ou pas
hansen et qu'ils y aient
vérifié aujourd'hui sur le site de l'om
s ils ces deux vaccins là sont
considérés comme faisant partie de
l'arsenal pour correct et le sino le
sinovac est considérée comme efficace à
100% sur les hospitalisations les formes
graves que je trouve dingue parce que on
a le côté scientifique où justement des
doutes émane de l'efficacité de ces
vaccins et à côté le côté un politique
obligé de le dire où on dit non non
c'est un très bon vaccin on savait alors
que l'om est sa discours totalement
politique là c'est ce que vous dites
c'est parti à l'enfance lobbying que
chaque état membre fait au sein de
chaque organisation de l'onu mais c'est
très haut au sein des organisations
onusiennes et très très bon de la part
de la chine en tous les cas inhabituels
mais on était justement jeu si jingping
parce que c'est intéressant c'était en
novembre dernier voilà ce qui dit sur
les vaccins
rochambeau
on retient sa les chiens fait les fans
qui vont suis dit himeur
chez jean-louis haïti et touche à tout
sôichi il est ouvrier et au cambodge à
l'échangé
traduit pour vous à jean joseph boillot
arsenic et un milliard de doses pour
l'afrique voilà ce que disait xi
jingping jean joseph boillot la chine
donc à exporter ses vaccins donc
enseigné qu'il vient de dire que l' oms
considère qu'ils sont en tout cas le
sinovac qu'il est efficace il les a
exporté en afrique au brésil cette
stratégie en fait est là qu'est ce
qu'elle apporte à la chine
alors d'abord je ne suis pas
épidémiologistes mais quand même je
crois que tout le monde est d'accord sur
une chose c'est qu'en gros par rapport à
des virus de ce type là les vaccins ne
sont jamais entre guillemets efficace à
100% d'accord non donc il faut vraiment
faire très attention mais encore à pas
tomber d'un extrême à l'autre mais
pardonner qu'ils disent au pays en fait
les pays pauvres dit ça en afrique ils
disent finalement préfère un vaccin peu
efficace que pas d'accent du tout
exactement donc c'est pour ça je dis
faisons attention parce que voyez à
tordre comme les américains de bâton
dans un sens 110 euros à monsieur pas
plus efficace ceci cela en réalité on ne
répond pas à une réalité simple qui est
que la chine c'est 70% des bassins qui
ont été fournis aux pays en voie de
développement je vérifie oui c'est ça 70
% sachant que l'inde face à la crise
terrible qui s'est produit en avril à
stopper totalement c'est fourniture de
vaccins c'est le c'est quand même le
premier ou deuxième producteur mondial
de vaccins avaient cessé ses fournitures
ou aux mécanismes cobat donc la
diplomatie du vaccin qui est grande
c'est tout à fait vrai ce qui était dit
tout à l'heure c'était la grande
victoire la chine et la grande gagnante
de la diplomatie du vaccin on ne voit
pas très bien à paris parce qu'on n'est
pas à montevideo et on n'est pas dakar
mais mes amis de dakar me disent par
exemple qu'à l'occasion de ce sommet
chine afrique s'est tenue à dakar cette
année en novembre lorsque le président
jean guy a mis sur la table à milliards
de vaccins dont 200 millions fabriquer
si j'ai bien compris en afrique si vous
voulez ça a été partout en afrique
partout en afrique à la lime de la
presse pourquoi c'est important tout à
l'heure j'ai parlé de la fuite mais
quand on parle de la fuite la stratégie
de la fuite il ya un autre concept
chinois qui est très important dans la
vie qui revient aujourd'hui au devant de
la scène dès réflexion doctrinale c'est
le trail c'est à dire le empire seles le
toit du ciel la chine ne veut pas se
refermer complètement sur elle-même du
tout mais elle veut construire une sorte
de parapluie donc son son parapluie de
10,6 l attitude de lempire céleste et de
ce point de vue là le vaccin mais aussi
des relations économiques si vous
regardez les relations économiques avec
l'afrique l'amérique latine et leurs
tresses de l'asie on l'oublié le premier
récipiendaire des taxes un chinois sap
et l afrique du tout c'était l'asie en
particulier l'asie du sud-est le
l'indonésie la thaïlande et c'est donc
c'est tout c'est une grande percée deux
côtés de la diplomatie chinoise que
d'avoir réussi à imposer un dock siens
que pas le meilleur mais qui au moins si
vous voulez et fournir des milliards
d'exemplaires attention la population
chinoise et maxime est alors justement
est ce qu'elle fait vacciner la
population chinoise hansen et rio où est
a priori ils ont commencé en même temps
finalement et la population et les
envois vers l'extérieur et pour rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit je pense que
la temporalité house a été fait est très
important symboliquement parce que
finalement cette géopolitique du vaccin
et la chine a commencé à exporter ces
vaccins
lorsque les pays occidentaux finalement
se sont jetés sur les premières doses
qui arrivait de pfizer et astrazeneca
dans un premier temps et finalement
l'occident qui avait dit à les vaccins
seront un bien commun de l'humanité bien
sûr on va vacciner toutes les personnes
vulnérables en même temps au printemps
en
2021 a bien vu que finalement l'occident
avait cohabité toutes les doses présente
de l'astre à zenica et c'est à ce moment
là où la chine a commencé la chine et la
russie d'ailleurs la chine et la russie
ont commencé justement à distribuer
leurs vaccins alors illusoire de penser
que ça n'est que des accords sur la
vaccination et on voyait bien de la part
de la chine tisséo rôti c'est finalement
et consolider les liens qu'elle
entretenait avec les différents pays sur
la nouvelle route de la soie et la
deuxième temporalité est d'autant plus
importante c'est lorsque à la vague au
micro n'arrive que tous les pays
contrairement à ce qu'ils ont tous signé
le règlement sanitaire international en
2005 ont refermé les frontières et la
chine qui arrive et qui dit nous allons
apporter un milliard de vaccins à
l'afrique tout ça alors que les
occidentaux continuent de se fractionner
tout d'abord vont communiquer sur les
premières doses qu'ils ont amené vers
l'afrique subsaharienne et qui était d
astra zeneca alors que dans le même
temps dans les semaines précédentes tous
les médias européens disaient que on ne
voulait plus en europe de l'astra zeneca
parce que il donnait des effets
secondaires elle car son épingle du jeu
en fait la chine a un petit mot and
sénéquier sur la rn message et j'ai lu
qu'il faisait une recherche sur ce
vaccin également arn messager lachine
oui de toute façon il ya deux cent
soixante trois candidats vaccins un
début 2020 aujourd'hui certains ont
arrêté mais oui il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs
comment dire types de vaccins qui sont à
l'étude et sans ça on fait partie
effectivement à la chine la chine a
sorti sinovac et sinopharm qui ne sont
pas des vaccins à rnm parce que c'était
une technologie sur laquelle ils
pouvaient compter qu'il gérait et qui du
coup ramener un résultat certain donc
ils ont pour mille paquets sur sur cette
première technologie et après derrière
commencé à travailler sur autre chose
après on ne sait pas tout non plus ce
qui se passe dans les laboratoires gym
il pourra en sortira c'est une
possibilité en tout cas bâtisse five
roses après les vaccins intéressante ou
même de se repencher justement sur les
jo de londres venait de parler les géo
qui commence dans quelques semaines avec
cette affaire pine trail et le boycott
diplomatique de plusieurs pays dont les
états unis les états unis le royaume uni
me semble-t-il il y en a parlé
l'australie et le japon qui s'y est
joint aussi et le japon donc ça fait
quatre pays cette joueuse de tennis
chinoise en a beaucoup entendu parler
peinture elle a évoqué le fait d'avoir
été violée par aux dirigeants du régime
de pékin à la disparue de la circulation
puis tout d'un coup on l'a revu qu'est
ce que est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour la chine que finalement ce boycott
diplomatique de la part de ses 1 2 3 4 5
pays au total ya le canada aussi
ce que c'est un camouflet vous savez je
pense encore une fois forcément la chine
pense à l'image qu'elle véhicule au
niveau international maintenant
est-ce que elle cherche aussi avant tout
et je pense que c'est aussi le cas à
réussir à tout prix ses jeux olympiques
vis-à-vis de cette de sa propre
population encore une fois en montrant à
sa population qu'elle est capable
d'organiser un événement sportif majeur
l'un des plus importants au monde en
pleine période de pandémie avec les
athlètes qui viennent avec des sponsors
donc comme choix oui forcément
d'ailleurs le fait que peu de choix y
est réapparu comme ça ça montre que la
chine a effectivement attentes et voilà
même après voilà moi en tout cas en tant
qu ancien correspondant en chine c'est
assez intéressant de voir à quel point
ça a provoqué un émoi ici en occident
parce que finalement des personnes qui
disparaissent du jour au lendemain ou
qu'on passe sous silence et puis que le
gouvernement ressort à travers des aveux
parfois forcés à travers
par exemple
assez courant qui arrivent assez
régulièrement en chine est là avec laura
l'importance internationale qui appelle
choisi en a beaucoup parlé ici et oui
oui je pense quand même que la chine
veut à tout prix réussir ces jeux
olympiques et d'ailleurs dans cette idée
de réussite il y à des jeux olympiques
qui ne seront pas perturbés par le cos
vide comme elle l'avait fait finalement
pendant l'exposition universelle de
shanghai comme l'avait fait pendant les
jo de pékin et à chaque fois d'ailleurs
comme on le voit en ce moment il ya un
resserrement très fort à tous les
niveaux pour que le pour que l'événement
se passe du mieux possible avant les jo
de pékin y avait eu des dizaines de
dissidents qui avaient arrêté avant
l'expo universelle de shanghai c'était
pareil avec une campagne
d'assainissement de la ville avec des
directives qui était assez improbable et
puis là bon aujourd'hui on voit que il
ne faut absolument pas que le virus
vienne entraver cette belle machine que
sont légion sur joseph boillot cinq pays
seulement pour boycotter
diplomatiquement cjo est ce que c'est un
camouflet pour la chine où finalement il
n'y en a pas eu suffisamment pour que ça
puisse avoir des conséquences
non c'est un camouflet pour l'occident à
gesco et moi il pour faire attention et
là encore il faut regarder les choses
qui a été dit précédemment est très
importante du point de vue de la
population chinoise d'accord donc c'est
ça qui est quand même le la cible dont
pas numéro 1 mais en tout cas c'est très
important en ce moment il ya des tas de
chinois pas quelques sons de skier sur
les pistes de ski etc on savait que le
nouvel an commence donc et pas comme des
chinois commencent la fin de la semaine
et donc on a des réservations son plein
dans les stations de ski que lâcher la
démultiplier ces dernières années avec
d'ailleurs toutes les technologies
françaises possibles et inimaginables de
de la savoie et autres pourquoi c'est un
camouflet plutôt pour l'occident parce
qu'on le voit bien la question pour la
chine c'est pas les états unis et on va
dire son allié le plus proche le canada
où l'ennemi numéro 1 du japon de la
chine qu'elle japon le problème c'est
que
fissurait le camp occidental c'est le
noeud de la guerre des plots ma pratique
de pékin fissuré l'unité occidental et
le fait que la finalement les etats-unis
se retrouvent avec je dire quatre autres
partenaires alors que l'europe ne bouge
pas je crois que c'est ça qui aurait été
d'ailleurs le président maquereau a
tenté et continue d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet de faire bouger les lignes mais
pour l'instant
face
à ces jeux olympiques c'est la
communauté internationale massivement
qui se retrouvent et là encore il faut
regarder les choses gaies la propagande
chinoise qu'il utilise ensuite c'est
boycott
elle va utilities qui boycotte pas ce
qu'elle va dire regardez c'est des
mauvais joueurs c'est des mots c'est de
toute façon il doutait
c'est très facile à la fois vis-à-vis de
la population chinoise mais aussi donc
c'est ce que je voulais dire il faut pas
regarder là encore le nord il faut
regarder le sud la chine se moque
relativement maintenant des pays du nord
c'est vraiment ça sa vision du monde
c'est l'hémisphère sud c'est le fameux
sud-sud pourquoi puisqu'il ya 80% à
population égale qui se trouve là tout
simplement et que les réserves de
croissance les bois par exemple à l'onu
ce ne sont pas les occidentaux qu'il est
qui les contrôlent maintenant c'est
l'été du sud et vis-à-vis des pays du
sud tant qu'un pays comme le brésil etc
ou l'indonésie
ne compte ne s'associe pas au boycott
c'est pour pékin une victoire donc il
faudra faire très attention peut-être
une dernier point le challenger
de pékin c'est quand même qu'on le
veuille ou non les jeux olympiques de
tokyo rappelez vous la situation de ces
jeux olympiques donc est-ce qu'il faut
absolument pour pékin c'est aux minima
réussir au moins aussi bien les jeux
olympiques qui se sont tenues à tokyo et
rappelez vous les jeux finalement se
sont relativement bien tenus il y avait
pas beaucoup de spectateurs mais il n'y
a pas eu de 2 rebonds épidémique suite à
ces jeux je pense que c'est la vision
cessé de la visée stratégique de la
chine à l'occasion de ces jeux annoncés
dès qu'il ya donc ça serait pékin contre
tokyo finalement la vraie rivalité qui
se joue avec ccg aux divers
c'est vrai que c'est un nom précédent
aussi le fait que les jo d'été et jo
d'hiver soit si proche donc on a tous en
tête et tous en mémoire ce qui s'est
passé effectivement l'été dernier à
tokyo et comment ne pas faire le
parallèle aujourd'hui avec avec ce qui
va se passer à pékin donc ce que l'on va
faire de manière inconsciente et
intuitive il est fort probable que ça
soit bien dans les esprits des
dirigeants chinois bien sûr bâtisse
falvo a justement un mot sur l'économie
puisque on a parlé santé il y a tout de
même on peut dire que la croissance
chinoise n'est plus exactement au beau
fixe comme auparavant il ya une faillite
de petites entreprises qui sont
multipliées pénalisé bien sûr par la
pandémie baptiste lac chine se prépare
tout de même à une croissance plus
faible alors qu'on est à quelques mois
vous le disais justement du
renouvellement du mandat de six jingping
comment justement va-t-il utiliser cela
si jingping parce que quelque part c'est
une faiblesse
chez jean ping façon bon il ay là il à
me développer plusieurs concepts ces
derniers mois pour préparer entre
guillemets ce renouvellement de mandat
il ya ce concept de prospérité commune
qui l'a mis en avant ces derniers mois
pour elle n'est plus si prospère la
chine elle et moi en tout cas alors elle
et moi les moins bons ça reste rappelons
quand même que pour 2020 ça reste la
seule grande nation entre guillemets
industrialisés qui a réussi à voir une
croissance positive en pleine pandémie
dont lé plus y prospère en tout cas oui
effectivement les chiffres ont été de la
croissance ont été assez fort en 2021
mais forcément il faisait écho à cette
croissance
si nul en 2020 la banque mondiale table
sur 5,1 pour cent de croissance pour
2022 donc là on est dans une dynamique
baissière vous avez évoqué toutes ces
faillites de petites entreprises
evergrande est aussi en libye lire la
question de la dette de l'endettement
des grands groupes immobiliers chinois
avec ce groupe donc il ya
restructuration en ce moment donc oui
oui oui il ya des questions qui se
posent la stabilité économique c'est
quelque chose qui revient vraiment sur
le devant de la scène après alors je ne
suis pas économie je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure ça va vraiment causé un
impact très important sur le plan
politique mais ce sont des défis qui se
font jour et qu'il n'était certainement
pas dans le viseur des autorités y
encore il ya encore deux ou trois ans et
jean joseph boillot puisque vous vous
êtes économiste est ce que ça va être un
cas un problème poursuit jean ping tout
de même c'est ces mois à venir avec ce
retour du virus puisque rial omicron une
économie qui est tout de même moins
florissante qu'il ya quelques années
à neuner parfait je suis économiste et
donc je vais vous répondre peut-être un
peu moins pessimiste car qu'est-ce qui
se passe si vous regardez à l'échelle du
monde ce qu'on appelait cibler les
chaînes de valeur ajoutée etc on avait
au début de la pandémie tous parier sur
un phénomène important de relocalisation
on sait pas du tout ce qui se passe
on n'a jamais vu d' usine du monde
fonctionner autant pour le monde et donc
et en même temps par éléments et en même
temps vous dites qu'elle vise à avoir
plus d'autarcie de vivre en autarcie
régine mais ce sont des gens très
empirique et de tanks et ils vont créer
je pense on est en train d'évoluer vers
une sorte non pas d'autarcie mais deux
pays fait on va dire qu'ils comptent
retour rapidement fermé mais dont les
marchandises c'est cool les technologies
rentrer et c'est
assez compliqué à comprendre parce que
on a résonné beaucoup sur le concept
d'isolationnisme tel qu'un moment donné
on a vraiment pensé que le le scénario
de la démondialisation c'aurait été le
repli soyez de chaque état sur soi et en
fait on est en train d'évoluer vers un
modèle qui est assez complexe c'est à
dire que l'économie chinoise
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
domaines
conserve un rôle central qu'elle a en
termes de fourniture regarder les
exportations chinoises vers les états
unis ne sont jamais aussi bien portés
par exemple
on n'a jamais vu autant de produits made
in china en france
donc il faut être très attention à cela
on a une économie qui a été dit tout à
l'heure est tout à fait exact qui a
ralenti mais si vous voulez attention
quand on passe de 10% de croissance à 5
% croissance ça donne l'impression que
c'est diviser par deux mais comme le
produit intérieur brut que la puissance
économique chinoise elle a été
multipliée par deux en l'espace de sept
ans en réalité 5% de croissance
aujourd'hui rajoute aux gâteaux chinois
plus qu'il ya dix ans de commencer qui
va relever les défis avant son fameux
congrès c'est jean ping dans les mois
qui viennent il va relever le défi donc
de la prospérité de justement ces
faillites de ses multiples entreprises
le défi n'est pas la croissance
je crois que le défi jean ping et de son
équipe
à lui il faut bien faire attention c'est
pas un homme qui gouverne la chine
insiste m d'accord leur défi c'est
d'arriver à cette transition du système
économique chinois du régime mais plutôt
je dirais du système économique chinois
qui est celui du laisser-faire de tennis
ping dans les années 78 81 pour
reprendre justement de l'ascendant
économique à celui d'une économie qui
deviendra une économie enfin lé dé facto
une superpuissance économique
aujourd'hui c'est indéniable mais elle
n'est pas dans le financier ou dans le
domaine mandat permet sur le plan on va
dire des grandes industries du monde
c'est vraiment une super puissance comme
les etats unis et pour eux l'important
est poursuivi mme king l'important c'est
d'assurer la transition vers un modèle
qui va devenir
autonome sait on entend beaucoup parler
de la voiture autonome et bien l'idée
c'est ça c'est faire en sorte que les
avions made in china remplacent les
bouygues etc que les vosges la presse
écrite par jean joseph boillot on n'y
est pas tout à fait justement
qui arrive
mais le fait est que c'est le pari sur
lequel j'ai impression on peut
comprendre pourquoi evergrande mais
aussi alibaba l'ensemble des grands
groupes chinois qui ont été le produit
de la libéralisation de les années thank
you ping l'ensemble de ces groupes en
réalité son gros client aujourd'hui
par une sorte de socialisme d'état ce
n'est plus un capitalisme d'état c'est
un socialisme d'état et qui s'appuie sur
si vous voulez des exagérations qu'il y
avait eu à l'air d'un c au pin en termes
de l'explosion des inégalités des
richesses etc
c'est assez compliqué il faut pas tout
de suite penser qu'ils vont gagner ou
qu'ils vont perdre c'est un processus
achats passés ainsi injecté juste une
orestie minutes peut-être que vous
concluez face à cette nouvelle vague
omicron
xi jingping activement sur sur cette
vague omikron ce qui est important c'est
de voir que finalement peu importe la
politique que l'on va mettre en place au
niveau national on a tous échouer
collectivement
au niveau international dans la gestion
de cette épidémie tout simplement parce
qu'elle est encore là tout simplement
parce qu'on a encore des vaccins on a
des vaccins on a des thérapeutiques de
plus en plus présente et finalement on
est toujours dans une unique 6 airbags
et partout dans le monde c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il faut questionner plus
tôt ce niveau national et cette
souveraineté nationale que chaque état
met en avant pour justifier sa gestion
du côté sanitaire mais il va falloir
penser collectif pour résoudre cette
pandémie avec la chine donc ça
l'excellent acceptent de coopérer aussi
parce que ce sont toujours ces règles
qu'elle met en avant oui c'est vrai mais
là on parle de la chine mais c'est vrai
pour tout le monde et finalement il n'y
a pas grand monde
sur notre planète cependant cette
pandémie qui a accepté de jouer
collectif finalement et là ce qu'on met
le focus sur la chine mais il faut aussi
regarder la façon dont on a géré les
choses nous et finalement personne n'a
été capable de penser collectif et de
coopérer vraiment un niveau qui
permettrait aujourd'hui de changer la
dynamique de la pandémie à plus de
coopération en tout cas serait très
rapide sur cette dynamique merci
beaucoup hansen et qui est d'avoir été
avec nous médecin co directrice de
l'observatoire de santé mondiale à
l'iris merci à vous jean joseph boillot
économie spécialiste de la chine à
l'iris merci batista merci de venir et
puis merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]